Oh. Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Star Wars
acolyte trailer that they dropped
that Star Wars celebration.
They didn't make it public,
So I have to be a little careful
about the way I do this breakdown.
But it's set during the High Republic
era, 100 years before the Phantom Menace.
Of course, I'll do episode videos for it
when it releases.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
It sounds like the release is going to be
sometime towards the middle,
maybe like the second half of 2024
because Star Wars Skeleton
Crew is going to be done before that.
That'll air
before acolyte Lee Jeong Jae from Squid
Game is playing a Jedi master who appears
very prominently in the trailer.
The actual trailer footage opens
at the Jedi Academy on Coruscant
with Lee Jong JS Jedi Master character
leading a class of younglings.
We don't know what his name
is, the name of his Jedi master.
There's a targe Jedi Padawan
character here that's Alien More
alien Jedi coming outside of Drogo
in Ahsoka and present day.
There aren't a ton of alien Jedi.
Maybe we'll see more during his voiceover,
he tells them.
Close your eyes.
Your eyes can be deceived.
We must not trust them.
That's meant to be foreshadowing
for the Sith group
that exists or the dark side practitioners
that are turning into the Sith
that will serve as the primary antagonist
during the series, hiding under the Jedi's
noses in plain sight.
Look, the whole idea is how was Palpatine
able to deceive the Jedi Council?
How is he able to exist
right under their noses?
It sounds like Lee Myung
Jay's
character is one of the few Jedi masters
during this period, about a hundred years
before Phantom Menace,
who senses
the Sith are becoming a great threat
again, like the dark side of the force
is starting to amass more power.
Whereas most of the Jedi Council
during this period,
The other Jedi don't believe that yet.
Like, for example, Yoda would still be on
the Jedi Council during this period.
It'd just be a much younger
version of Yoda.
But the idea is they become so dogmatic
that they don't think
that the dark side is a problem
because during the High Republic era,
that's meant to be like peak Jedi era.
They're more Jedi alive
and active in the galaxy
than any other period
in the history of the galaxy.
So the Jedi Order has become so powerful,
they become so overconfident
in themselves.
They're not really worried
about the dark side of the force,
which is where you get to the beginning
of their downfall.
Like the series is charting the beginning
of the end of the Jedi Order, he said.
His Jedi explores a lot of complex
emotions in a way that modern
Jedi during the fall of the Republic
the prequels era had abandoned,
which makes him sound a little bit
more like Qui-Gon Jinn,
which the Star Wars people like George
Lucas, Dave Filoni have talked about
when comparing quite gone into the other
Jedi masters from the prequels.
These are the quite gone.
Jinn was meant to be more like
the really old school Jedi from a long ago
in the Old Republic,
the High Republic era.
There were more willing
to embrace the living force
and they tried to follow the true
will of the force as opposed to what
the Jedi Council wanted them to do,
quite often ultimately tried to follow
the will of the living force as opposed to
the goals
that were put out by the Jedi Council,
like the will of the Masters versus
serving the true intentions of the force
itself.
George Lucas was really big on
this idea, too, that the Jedi,
by the events of the prequels, had grown
too dogmatic and stuck in their ways
before Order 66 goes down
in a big part of Antique and Skywalker.
Being this child of the force
meant to bring balance to the forces.
Prophecy about the force
was all about balancing the dark side
with the light side, and part of that
was mannequin balancing the light side out
so that the future force practitioners
might return to something
more akin to the bend
do in the way quite on jinn practice
the force as opposed to writing up
a Bible of their own
rules, their own interpretation,
and following that instead, then we see
Amandla Stenberg as mystery lead character
walking through a city here,
getting ready to attack Carrie-Anne Moss,
Jedi master character.
You notice
the structure here that she walks under
is right out of the Ralph McCary
concept art.
They also use that same structure
during The Force Awakens on Jakku,
but I don't think this plan is
meant to be jakku as she continues to walk
through the markets on the street.
Lee Jeong J's Jedi master character
goes on saying the force is powerful
as a man less than approaches
Carrie-Anne Moss character,
He ends his voiceover
by saying It is power.
We must respect
respecting the power of the force.
As you see Carrie-Anne
Moss get into a knockdown, drag out
martial arts
fight with or without lightsabers.
Amandla Stenberg characters using two
knives, the kind of the tone of the show,
which is very
much inspired by martial arts
films, legacy.
The fight scene is inspired by classic
Wushu kung fu movies
like The Matrix, Carrie-Anne
Moss coming from the Matrix movies.
So this is very familiar.
Maybe we'll get some terracotta Jedi
martial arts references and Easter eggs.
They also have the team that did
all the fights for the Shang-Chi movie,
so it sounds like
they're going to be hard core.
Then we see Charlie Bartlett's
Jedi character get some brief screentime.
Then the in the trailer
by getting ready for a real gritty
knock down, drag out lightsaber battle
with eight Jedi, igniting
their lightsabers,
including Daphne Keane's Jedi character.
We know how to do that.
We had a couple like off
screen saber fights.
Yeah, we did. Oh, Daphne broke a saber.
No, shush.
Why would you say that?
Actually, yeah, actually,
if it was three, but true.
And they come in like private briefcases,
too, so it's like it was, you know.
No, it was really bad.
It was.
It was actually the prop people were like,
you need to stop.
And I was like, I'm really sorry.
I'm not doing it on purpose.
Most of you
remember her as x 23 from the Logan movie,
even though it was cut off
during some of the footage
that was released from the trailer online.
Briefly,
there was a brief shot of in the movie.
And during this two,
they're from the trade federation
figure heavily into the separatist
and the beginning of what happens
during Phantom Menace.
They revealed that Jason Su Amo,
who plays Chewbacca in the sequel trilogy,
is going to be playing the Wookie
Jedi, who I believe is meant to be BR Yaga
Right now, a little bit earlier
in the timeline,
during all the comics in the books
that they're doing during the High
Republic era, he's a Jedi Padawan,
but I believe by the events of this series
he'll become a full Jedi Knight.
Rebecca Henderson is playing Vanessa Rowe,
who appears during this other High
Republic comics
that stories are doing right now.
But by the events of this series,
she's become a Jedi master.
The official plot synopsis just reads,
The Acolyte is a mystery thriller
that will take viewers
to a galaxy of shadowy secrets in emerging
dark side powers in the final days
of the High Republic era.
Which is why I see it takes place
closer to the events of Phantom Menace.
A former Padawan reunites with her Jedi
master to investigate a series of crimes.
But the forces they confront are
more sinister than they ever anticipated.
So it's sort of the idea of the Sith
rearing their heads again,
because up to the events
of Revenge of the Sith,
the Emperor had kept the Sith
relatively quiet and under the radar.
The same was true of his master,
Darth Plagueis,
and then all the way back to Darth Bane.
That was all part of the rule of two
to stay under the radar
so that the Jedi wouldn't bother them.
So they're implying that at least
a couple of the Jedi will discover
that the Sith are alive and well
and continuing to practice
and something bad
will probably happen to them
to prevent them from telling someone
like Master Yoda, for instance, who's
still very much alive in much younger
during this period in the timeline.
So you think that a much younger
version of Yoda would be much quicker
to jump on the Sith problem?
Like, Oh, we got to take care of that
right now, nip it in the bud.
It just means
something is going to stop those Jedi
that discover it from telling the truth.
To the rest of the Jedi Council.
The main character is being played
by Amandla Stenberg,
and she's playing someone called Aura.
She's the person that gets tied up
with this acolyte group of characters
trying to become Sith apprentices.
You know, she's wearing a T-shirt
from the Mandalorian
that's a Mandalorian T-shirt,
keeping it in the Star Wars family.
Many Jacinto also just joined the series.
You remember him from The Good Place,
Jodie Turner-Smith,
Rebecca Henderson, Dean Charles Chapman,
who most of you remember
is Tommen from the Game of Thrones series.
I did episode videos for all those.
They didn't say
who most of them are playing.
The only one we really know a lot about
is the main character, Amandla Stenberg.
This Ora character, supposedly
the way that the Acolyte episode one
is meant to pick up is that it
starts on a planet called Sanshiro,
where she and her sister are from
is a world mostly made up of marshland,
snowy mountains in this aura character.
And her sister,
her family live in a village
that's frequently attacked
by primitive tribal beings.
They get attacked
during the events of episode one in there,
fought off by the Jedi of that period.
And because Aura is far more sensitive
after that first attack,
they take aura with them for training,
but they leave her sister behind.
So she's separated from her family.
Very standard practice for the Jedi
to separate people from their families,
all about attachments.
Not good thing.
Everybody saw the prequels.
We know how that went down
for Anna and Skywalker.
That's why most of the time when Jedi
are taken from their families, it's
before they've been able
to form attachments to them like before.
They're old enough to actually form
memories.
That's why Obi-Wan Kenobi
can barely remember his own family.
He even talked about that
during the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
Like there's an Obi-Wan Kenobi brother
that's alive somewhere in the galaxy.
There's another Kenobi
out there somewhere.
But when the Jedi take Laura to start her
training, the village is attacked again.
The Jedi are too late in her grandparents
wind up getting killed off.
And because her grandparents were killed,
her sister is left alone.
She doesn't want to leave her sister,
but the Jedi won't let her
take her sister with her back to course
on the Jedi Temple.
So you start to see the conflict
in the reason
why she starts to hate the Jedi and starts
down the dark path to the Sith.
Leslie likes to say that the show is a combination of frozen and cowbell, which is
kind of a nice
combo because of the relationship
between the sisters.
At the beginning of the series,
the main characters
in how the main character evolves
into more of a dark version of Uma
Thurman's bride character during Kill Bill
going on an epic revenge quest.
Except she's trying to get revenge
against the Jedi Order,
as you see during the trailer,
she goes up against Carrie-Anne Moss
as Jedi master character,
having a knockdown, drag out
martial arts fight with the Jedi master.
Once she starts down the dark path,
eventually she joins a group of acolytes.
Thus the title of the show,
a group of dark side force trainees
that are trying
to become Sith apprentices.
And it sounds like
all these acolytes are forced to perform
a bunch of trials and fight each other in.
The winner will become
the next Sith Apprentice,
and that's their way of working
within the canon.
The rule of two.
There must only ever be two officials
at any given time, but
there are many dark side force users
like you have this group of acolytes,
but they're not traditional Sith yet.
Remember the difference between Sith
and just regular dark side Force users?
The Sith were actually a race of beings
that intermingled
with a bunch of dark side force users
that kind of took over their culture
eventually.
What happened,
though, is that there was this great Jedi
Sith War about a thousand years ago.
Darth Vader wound up
being the only member of the Sith Order
to survive that he created the rule of two
to help the Sith persevere,
and thus it's continued to present day
long before that, when the dark side
force users took over the Sith culture
and started intermarrying
intermingling with them.
It was more of a traditional build up
this giant Sith empire and then conquer
the galaxy kind of thing, where you have
many, many Sith practitioners.
The whole idea of going forward
after Darth
Bane is that they would stay off the radar
and thus the Jedi wouldn't
think of them as a threat
or even think about them at all.
But one of the things they're going to do
during the series
is that it won't just be like Breaking Bad
in the Star Wars universe.
I mean, it might be a little bit of that
is it'll show you why some of the things
that the Jedi were teaching
were bad, like why the Jedi order
became kind of stagnant.
The idea with Grogu, whose character later
during the events of The Mandalorian
and him rejecting
Luke Skywalker in the Jedi Order,
is their way of showing you that Grogu
who is rejecting the old Jedi Order?
Because that's kind of what's going on
with Luke Skywalker's Jedi temple.
That's the reason why it failed
during the events of the sequel movies,
because he started to make
the same mistakes
as the old Jedi Order because he was
trying to teach the old Hit's basically
like he was trying to orchestrate his Jedi
temple and his teachings
the same way that the old Jedi Order did,
like play the hits.
So the whole promise with the Grogu's
character much later in the timeline
and hopefully this will play out
in future series in future movies,
is that we'll see Grogu you take the Jedi
Order in a completely new direction
that's completely different
from the Jedi that came before, like Yoda.
But just remember
that Grogu is only about 50 years old.
During the events of The Mandalorian, he's
about the same age as Anna and Skywalker,
which is why we have all those theories
about how there might be a twist
with the prophecy that the child,
the prophecy might not just be Mannequin
Skywalker, it could also be Grogu
who, like Grogu,
will also bring balance to the force.
Like I said, just
based on what they've talked about
with the timeline of the series,
the closest we get to like really big
Easter egg characters would be like very,
very young version of Palpatine.
You ever hear
the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the wise?
We've been making the jokes
about Palpatine and his master, Darth
Plagueis, for so many years now.
Palpatine won't yet
be old enough to become Plex's apprentice
at the end of the series.
Like this is meant to take place
a little bit before that,
so we might actually see Darth
Plagueis show up during the series
and then pay off
some of his research into defying death,
influencing the middle chlorians to either
create or extend life.
That was the whole tale
that he was telling to.
And again, Skywalker,
he was basically trying to explain to him
in so many words
how he essentially learned
how to influence the middle chlorians
in this master life and death
and then kill his master. Like,
that's the whole idea is
that they're only ever to Sith
at any given time.
And usually the apprentice winds up
killing the master.
And that's how you become a Sith master.
So that also might be
one of the big twists in the series
is that when the main character becomes
a Sith apprentice, eventually he will kill
whoever the master winds up being
and because this is mostly
a synth based series,
I don't know how much time we're going
to spend on Coruscant with other people
like the younger Yoda
and the other Jedi during that era.
We also just got the Ahsoka
extended trailer.
There was an Ahsoka panel
where they talk more about the series.
They revealed that Lars
Mikkelsen is coming back as Thrawn
in they release another felt like
a second trailer with a whole bunch
more footage
and I'll do a breakdown of that tomorrow.
My Full Mandalorian Season three Episode
seven Video We'll also post on Wednesday
after they release that there's
going to be a bunch of big reveals
pushing into the Ahsoka series,
which is going to air later this year.
So just a reminder that the Acolyte series
isn't meant to be connected
to the Mandalorian or the Thrawn plot
that's happening right now.
It's at 100 years before Phantom Menace
and is dealing with a completely different
series of events in the
setting up a completely different part
of the timeline.
Everyone click here for my Ahsoka
trailer video and click here to learn
about all the brand new Star Wars movies
like the Thrawn movie that they're making.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.